what is more effective at making a net
positive impact on the world empathy or
Reason
it depends on what you mean by empathy
there are two at least two kinds of
empathy there's the
the cognitive form which is
you know I would argue even a species of
reason it's it's just understanding
another person's point of view you know
you understand
why they're suffering or why they're
happy or what you know we just you have
a theory of mind
about another human being that is is
accurate and so you can
you can navigate uh in relationship to
them more effectively
um and then there's an another layer
entirely not incompatible with that but
just distinct which is what people often
mean by empathy which is more
a kind of emotional contagion right like
you feel depressed and I begin to feel
depressed along with you because you
know it's just it's contagious right I I
you know we're so close and I'm so
concerned about you and your problems
become my problems and it bleeds through
right now I think both of those
capacities are very important but
um the emotional contagion piece
uh and this is not really my thesis this
is something I have more or less learned
from from Paul Bloom
um
the psychologists uh who wrote a book on
this topic titled against empathy
um the emotional social contagion piece
is a bad guide rather often for ethical
behavior and ethical intuitions oh boy
and uh so I'll give you the the clear
example of this which is
uh we
find
stories with a single identifiable
protagonist who we can effortlessly
empathize with
far more compelling than data right so
if I tell you you know this is the
classic case of the little girl who
falls down a well right you know this is
some Somebody's Daughter you see the
parents uh distraught on television uh
you hear her Cries From the Bottom of
the well the whole country stops I mean
this this was an example of this you
know 20 25 years ago I think where it
was just wall-to-wall on CNN this is
just the perfect use of CNN it was you
know 72 hours or whatever it was of
continuous coverage of just extracting
this girl from a well
so we effortlessly pay attention to that
we care about it we will donate money
toward it I mean it's just it Marshals
100 of our compassion and altruistic
impulse
um whereas if you hear that there's a
genocide raging in some country you've
never been to and never intended to go
to and the numbers don't make a dent and
the and we we find
the story boring and we'll change the
channel in the face of a genocide right
it doesn't matter and it literally it
perversely it could be 500 000 little
girls have fallen down wells in that
country and we still don't care right so
um it's uh you know many of us have come
to believe that this is a bug rather
than a feature of our moral psychology
and so the the empathy plays an
unhelpful role there so ultimately I
think
when we're making big decisions about
what we should do and how to mitigate
human suffering and what's worth valuing
and how we should protect those values
um I think reason is the better tool but
it's not that I would want to dispense
with any part of empathy either well
there's a lot of changes to go on there
but briefly to mention you've recently
talked about effective altruism on your
podcast I think you mentioned some
interesting statement I'm going to
horribly misquote you but
that you'd rather live in a world like
it doesn't really make sense but you'd
rather live in a world where you care
about maybe your daughter and son more
than 100 people that live across the
world something like this like where the
calculus is not always perfect but
somehow it makes sense to live in a
world where it's irrational in this way
and yet empathetic in the way you've
been discussing right I'm not sure what
the right answer is there or even
whether there is one right answer there
could be multiple you know Peaks on on
this part of the moral landscape but so
the opposition is between an ethic
that's articulated by someone like the
Dalai Lama right or really any exponent
of of um
you know classic Buddhism would say that
these are the ultimate enlightened ethic
is true dispassion with respect to
friends and strangers right so that you
would the you know the mind of the
Buddha would be
truly dispassionate you would love and
care about all people equally uh and by
that light it seems some kind of ethical
failing or at least you know failure of
of to really fully actualize compassion
in the limit or you know enlightened
wisdom in the limit
um to care more or even and much more
about your kids than the kids of other
people or and to prioritize your your
energy in that way right so you spend
all this time trying to figure out how
to keep your kids healthy and happy and
you'll attend to their minutest concerns
and however superficial and and again
there's a genocide raging in Sudan or
wherever and it takes up less than one
percent of your bandwidth I'm not sure
it would be a better world if everyone
was running the Dalai Lama program there
I think some prioritization of
one's nearest and dearest uh ethically
might be optimal because we'll all be
doing that and we'll all be doing that
in
a circumstance where we have certain
norms and and laws and and other
structures that Force us to be
dispassionate where that matters right
so like when I go to
when my daughter gets sick I have to
take her to to a hospital
you know I really want her to get
attention right and I'm worried about
her more than I'm worried about everyone
else in the lobby but the truth is I
actually don't want a totally corrupt
hospital I don't want a hospital that
treats my daughter better than anyone
else in the lobby because she's my
daughter and I have you know bribed the
guy at the door or whatever you know the
guy's a fan of my podcast or whatever
the thing is you don't want starkly
corrupt unfair situations
and when you're when you sort of get
pressed down the hierarchy of Maslow's
needs you know individually and and
societally
a bunch of the bunch of those variables
change and they change for the worse
understandably but yeah when things are
when everyone's corrupt and it's you're
you're in a state of of uh Collective
emergency you know you've got a Lifeboat
problem you're scrambling to get into
the Lifeboat yeah then then fairness and
norms and and
um the you know the the other vestiges
of civilization
begin to get stripped off we can't
reason from those emergencies to normal
life I mean in normal life we want
Justice we want fairness we want we're
all better off for it even when the
spotlight of our concern is focused on
the people we know the people who are
friends the people who are family people
we we have good reason to care about
we still by default want a system that
protects the the interests of strangers
too and and we know that generally
speaking interesting in game theoretic
terms we're all going to tend to be
better off in a fair system than a
corrupt one